عندما تضيق بين الارض نرتقي الى اعلى فكره
الهمت مبدعي حدائق بابل المعلقه في القرن
السادس قبل الميلاد
وتقوم على شكل شروفات المتبرجه مزروعه
بالنباتات تسقى على مدى العام انها اول
تجربه لزراعه العموديه مفهوم الحفز علماء
في السويد لايجاد طرق مبتكره للزراعه
لتلبيه الحاجات المتزايده من الغذاء
للاستهلاك البشري عائد خالي تعديلات
جوهريه عليها
المنتج النهائي والنباتات الماكوله هنا
تجري عمليه الانبات وبعدها تاتي مرحله
المشتل حيث تنضج النباتات في ظروف مناسبه
حتى تصبح قويه وكبيره بما يكفي لنقلها
غرسها
تزرعوا هذه النباتات على مرمى حجر من
المكان الذي تباع فيه تقع هذه المزرعه
العموديه داخل متجر الفستقرد مشروع اطلقته
شركه سبيجرين المتخصصه في الزراعه الرقميه
والدعم التكنولوجي عام 2019
تعد المزرعه واحده من وحدات كبيره في
السويد مصممه خصوصا للسوبر ماركت وما تاجر
ترزيه
الفائقه ولذلك ابتكرنا طريقه لانتاج
الغذاء بالمعنى الفائق في محل السوبر
ماركت والمطاعم ومتاجر التجزئه ونقوم بذلك
بطريقه مختلفه اذ ننتج المواد الغذائيه من
البذره الى النبته الناضجه بشكل كامل داخل
المحل لنفسها
بدات الزراعه العموديه تنتشر اكثر فاكثر
في العالم اما نظام زراعه فيها فلم يعرف
بزراعه المائيه اي دوله تربه حيث تستنبه
النباتات في احواض خاصه مرتبطه في ما
بينها بشبكه انابيب تطخ فيها مياه الري
والمغذيات الاساسيه اللازمه لنمو النباتات
يتم ذلك في بيئه يتحكم فيها بدرجه الحراره
والضوء والرطوبه والغازات ما يجعل انتاج
الاطعمه والادويه الداخليه ممكنه يقول
القائمون على المشروع انه يمكن للمتاجر
باستخدام مزارعهم العموديه ان تحصد يوميا
ما يصل الى 450 نبته وبهذا سيكون لديهم
فرصه انتاج محاصيل طازج يوميا دون الحاجه
الى نقلها
بالمبيدات الحشريه
يامرو رواه الزراعه العموديه في السويد ان
يصبح نموذجهم الزراعي متاحا في 80% من
المتاجر الكبرى بالعالم للسنوات المقبله